el g7 busca resolver las consecuencias
de la guerra en ucrania los líderes de
las democracias más ricas del mundo
abordaron en un castillo de los alpes
bávaros temas relacionados con la crisis
medioambiental la economía global la
salud las exportaciones y las cadenas de
suministro entre otros una de las
grandes conclusiones fue la posibilidad
de prohibir el transporte de petróleo
ruso que se venda por encima de un
determinado precio una decisión que
aumenta la presión occidental sobre
rusia y busca agotar las arcas de moscú
aumentaremos nuestra vigilancia ante las
amenazas incluida la conversión
económica que pretende socavar la
seguridad y estabilidad mundial para
ello buscaremos una mayor cooperación y
exploraremos mecanismos para mejorar la
evaluación la preparación la disuasión y
la respuesta a dichos riesgos
el presidente de eeuu joe biden anunció
que las naciones del grupo prohibir a
las importaciones de oro provenientes de
rusia italia propuso la posibilidad de
limitar el precio del gas rusos mientras
francia pidió que se limiten los precios
de todas las ventas de energía y
su discusión concluyó claramente lo que
sale de nuestras discusiones y
conclusiones no es que occidente esté
opuesto al resto del mundo sino unido en
la pasa en contra de la guerra el océano
puede y no va a ganar y por lo tanto
nuestro apoyo a ucrania en nuestras
sanciones contra rusia van a continuar
durante el tiempo que sea necesario y
con la intensidad que sean necesarias el
g7 también ayudará en la financiación de
las necesidades inmediatas de ucrania
así como la reconstrucción de su
economía a largo plazo y aunque el grupo
de los siete planea destinar 4500
millones de dólares a la lucha contra el
hambre en el mundo el programa mundial
de alimentos de la onu aseguró que se
necesitarán como mínimo 22 mil 200
millones de dólares este año para
afrontar lo que han denominado la peor
crisis de hambre en una generación